and each of the teams arrived at
technological heart of usa here
enjoying with our expert
technological our first session
talking about android and designing
video games and a message for all
Latin American developers that by
course they die to develop
video games and video game design in
android my name is brand olivera and what
he worked on the google gaming team
and the truth is good, my work is called
deviated but legis so that's how I do
some code had a goal apart from
thin but james jones that is this from
talk to developers my talk today
it was about game design
present as what are the best
the best ways to do that with
game have an excellent experience
of user and has also submitted
our gaming platform on google
what is google games then it is a
platform that allows you to see it
for how to make games that have more
engagement
but no
plus
Y
ok well we keep on this money but
you 2013 edition silicon valley we follow
enjoying all the adrenaline
technology together with the experts of
google obviously that we come to
visit and enjoy with each one of
the equipment of course this
technological exchange in this case
we have josé tomás steroid aka bear
that came to talk a little about and
to comment of course on thinking
and about specific issues that I
would like to ask the question of many
thank god or for joining us and for
course a summary of what you were
conversing with each of the team and you
final impression of these guys that
come from Latin America with all the
talent to the silicon valley good the
true that he was presenting a
technology ours that suspense is that
You wear portbou to force us
allows to generate data types for
to be able to communicate through the network or
through the disk I was quite surprised
in fact I am very pleasantly
surprised at the level and attention
that the guys gave during this
presentation is true because we were
seeing questions and even
he was asked questions that have
responded quite well in fact
that surprises me that indeed the
level of attention they maintained in the
presentation was quite high which
speaks very well of the exact group that is
that we invite you who are there for
supposedly listening to us to use
open-source tools that you know
much more as they said for others is going to
do let's say one of the features
and that inspirational final message for
the entire ecosystem of Latin America
including the chile that is your heart in
your alma mater of course I dream about
many how to make me approach you
personally he loves it very much and defines
much the way that works that we have
us someone in google makes them
according to an idea and bring it to fruition
perfect this is the final message and
we continue to enjoy this developer
2013 edition voice here in the heart
Valley Silicon Valley